hey everyone bandit here and it's 44
days until breath of the wild 2 will
have been revealed to the general public
for a whopping
two whole years two years
let me tell you times have never been
weirder on the one hand we have people
leaking stuff about nintendo and breath
of the wild 2 every other day with
playable zelda this and changeable
hairstyles that and green zone eye hand
revealed gadgets blah blah blah
and on the other hand we're facing the
oncoming inevitable doom and takeover of
humankind due to the robotic invention
of ai wherein the best of us will be
captured and used as slaves for the rest
of our lives
so in the midst of our inevitable
takeover of robot kind i figured
who has the time to wait for news on
breath of the wild too am i right
why don't we use that ai while we still
can
and have it tell us the story of breath
of the wild too so without further ado
sit back
relax and enjoy some good old ai
storytelling before it tries to kill us
all
oh and real quick you better like this
video if you like this video and
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more content to come
or i'll tell the ai where you live
i'm just kidding i wouldn't do that to
you
because it already knows okay so the
first one that i found is called talk to
transformer i actually found this one
from an article on the verge
uh but it looks like what you do is you
basically just give it a little primer
paragraph and then it's just gonna go
ahead and write a story for you so here
we go
let's get elon musk out of here uh use a
custom
prompt okay what am i gonna write link
and
zelda go exploring in a dark
deep cave uh they stumble across the
uh long dead corpse of one ganondorf
the ground crumbles and the duo fall
to the area beneath
however link is caught by a mysterious
green hand
oh my goodness it oh my goodness it just
figured out that i wanted to use torches
and seriously that's all that i gave it
oh wow this is exciting what's uh
a little bit scary actually let's read
this in just a second alright ai number
one says link and zelda go exploring in
a dark deep cave
they stumble across the long dead corpse
of one ganondorf
the ground crumbles and the duo fall to
the area beneath
however link is caught by a mysterious
green hand
with the use of a series of torches the
two make their way to a place of green
light at the top of a mountain
link proceeds to enter the deep hole and
meets a mysterious being who offers him
a new life by dropping him into a larger
version of the first dungeon called the
emerald grounds
and then teleports away he meets link's
mother
wearing the mantle of princess zelda and
the two of them go on to the fountain of
light
a new dungeon is opened and link is sent
to save princess zelda
this is cool not even gonna lie kind of
iffy about the whole lynx mother
wearing the mantle of princess zelda
type thing going on there but
it's intriguing i almost want to see
more but we're moving on to the next one
all right now we have one called
sassbookai writer
points already am i right looks like we
give it some keywords and then we give
it a prompt
kind of like the last one and then it's
going to go ahead and write in some
stuff for us
i'm just gonna go ahead and skip through
here okay so for my prompts i put in
zelda link ganondorf green hand torch
and cave which seems pretty accurate
given what we see in the breath of the
wild 2 trailer and for my prompt i
actually had to cut it down a little bit
because it doesn't want me to go over 30
words
pretty darn good if you ask me but let's
see what the ai has to say about it
okay link and zelda are exploring a cave
they stumble across ganondorf dead for
many years as the ground crumbles
beneath them a mysterious green hand
lunges forward to save link
the legend of zelda a link between
worlds is an action adventure game
developed by nintendo ead
did it just google search the legend of
zelda i can't tell if this is
the dumbest or smartest thing that the
ai could have done like has ai evolved
to the point to where it's lazy
and it's just like let me google search
it that's like the greatest
characteristic of being human
is the ability to be lazy maybe they'll
be too lazy to take over maybe they
won't divide and conquer all of us
anyway this one was kind of lame let's
go to the next one
okay now this one actually looked
legitimately very interesting
uh it had me give it a whole bunch of
different like prompts and you know
keywords and protagonists
secondary characters stuff like that um
and then it's apparently going to
produce a story at the end so i'll go
over what i put in it real quick
oh and my pen name clearly mr banned it
all right
it's finally time write me a short story
okay i've glanced at it and it's um i'm
going to read this as
seriously as i can and you better not
laugh either the fun sword
a short story by mr bandit
link link had always loved deep cave of
ganon
with its grubby grim glowy rocks
it was a place where he felt scared he
was a cool
serious water drinker with blonde neck
and blue head
his friends saw him as a knobbly knowing
knight once he had even helped a wooden
big cow animal cross the road that's the
sort of man he was
link walked over to the window and
reflected on his rocky surroundings
the unknown teased like exploring cow
then he saw something in the distance or
rather someone
it was the figure of zelda hyrule zelda
was a sad princess with fit neck and
short head
link gulped he was not prepared for
zelda
as link stepped outside and zelda came
closer he could see the weak glint in
her eye
zelda gazed with the affection of 1343
mad big boar she said in hushed tones
i love you and i want to eat a frog
link looked back even more hungry and
still fingering the fun sword
well excuse me princess he replied
they looked at each other with curious
feelings like too relieved rare
rat delving at a very glad exploration
which had reverse audio piano music
playing in the background and two rad
uncles falling to the beat
link regarded zelda's fit neck and short
head i feel the same way
revealed link with a delighted grin
zelda looked brave
her emotions blushing like a tricky
testy torch
then zelda came inside for a nice drink
of water
the end
oh there's more there's more it even
auto-generates some reviews
from the daily tale i feel like i know
link link in a way it feels
as though i've always known him ended
kibler says
about as enjoyable as being hailed on
whilst
taking in washing that has been targeted
by seagulls with the squits
hit the spoof says saying the unknown
teased like exploring cow
is just the kind of literary device that
makes this brilliant and zob gloop says
i could do better
i feel like these are all different ai
raiding this ai's
story that was so good
we have to do another one we have to do
another one and this time we're going to
make it serious
all right it's going to be really really
serious this time
all right going through this very
quickly
[Music]
all right guys here we go this is the
serious story
the dank cave of ganon a short story by
mr bandit
zelda hyrule looked at the pointy cape
in her hands and felt scared
she walked over to the window and
reflected on her scary surroundings
she had always hated dank cave of ganon
with its grieving graceful glowy rocks
it was a place that encouraged her
tendency to feel scared
then she saw something in the distance
or rather someone
it was the figure of link link link was
a tenacious warrior with a pretty neck
and tall hand
zelda gulped she glanced at her own
reflection
she was a smart serious monster drinker
with blonde neck and green hand
her friends saw her as a straight square
scientist
once she had even saved a handsome girl
that fell down that was stuck in a drain
but not even a smart person who had once
saved a handsome girl that fell down
that was stuck in a drain was prepared
for what link had in store
that day the smog teased like
walking cow making zelda fearful as
zelda stepped outside and link came
closer she could see the decaying
smile on his face i am here because i
want to not
die link bellowed in a determined tone
he slammed his fist against
zelda's chest with a force of 3875
bore i freaking love you zelda hyrule
sorry sorry zelda looked back even more
fearful and still fingering the pointy
cape
link i did not like you at first but now
i do
she replied they looked at each other
with afraid feelings
like too ratty ravel snatching rat
falling
at a very dangerous adventure which had
piano music playing in the background
and two intelligent uncles running to
the beat
zelda regarded link's pretty neck and
tall hand
she held out her hand let's not fight
she whispered gently hmm
pondered link please begged zelda with
puppy dog eyes
link looked hurt his body blushing like
an abundant aggressive altar
ben link came inside for a nice drink of
monster
the end well guys there you have it the
story
of breath of the wild 2 told to us a few
different ways
by ai let me know what you guys thought
of this in the comments below
let me know if you like this kind of
video and if you want to see ai come up
with different
uh scenarios and maybe if you want me to
read them to you heck
like this video so it gets spread around
to like an animator or something that
can actually
animate this greatness that we just read
right here let's make this big why not
and once again remember to subscribe if
you haven't already for much more zelda
content to come we've got a lot to look
forward to this summer
so i'm hoping to see you all there
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is massington abandoned signing out
peace
[Music]
you